So Donald Trump continues to deny that he
had many strokes.
And again, this is only raising more questions
because the upcoming book from Michael Schmidt
from The New York Times doesn't allege Trump
had strokes.
And Trump continuing to bring it up is starting
to put more attention on it.
Then there would be otherwise.
And the backstory, of course, is that Michael
Schmidt's book claims that when Donald Trump
abruptly went to Walter Reed Hospital in 2019
for that unscheduled visit, that it was some
kind of urgent.
Medical situation, he doesn't say what kind
it was, but he does say that Mike Pence was
put on notice, be prepared to take over as
president because Donald Trump may need to
go under anesthesia.
Trump has brought up this issue of mini strokes,
which is not a claim that's actually made
in the book.
Trump introduces the idea of strokes in a
tweet last week where he said, quote, It never
ends.
Now they are trying to say that your favorite
president, me, went to Walter Reed Medical
Center, having suffered a series of mini strokes,
never happened to this candidate.
Fake news.
Perhaps they're referring to another candidate
from another party.
Then Trump brings it up again during this
Latrobe, Pennsylvania, Corona rally, which
I covered last week.
Trump spent several minutes on this, again,
telling this totally implausible story that
he said, hey, you know what?
Let's go over to Walter Reed last minute to
get a jump on next year's physical.
It was never believable.
But again, Trump brings up mini strokes.
Take a look at this.
The new one is, you know, I went for a physical.
The doctor said to me, sir, would you like
to go to Walter Reed?
It's incredible.
By the way, the job they do on people that
have been just really hurt our heroes at the
job they do is incredible.
But, sir, would you like to go over and do
a physical?
You have some time.
You know why I had time, some deal.
Oh, it was China.
I decided not to see China because they didn't
like the way they were doing business.
OK.
Does that make sense?
So the doctor, White House doctor, highly
respected Sean Sean Connelly.
Sir, would you like to go over and do your
physical, do a piece of it or finish it or
whatever it was?
But do as I said, I don't know.
I'm not in love with the idea.
Well, let's say if you do it, we don't have
to do it.
Okay, let's go.
Come on.
So we went.
We went.
And we're driving now.
You have to understand, there are like a hundred
cars.
You see what happens here?
It's like the plane times 50.
So the cars are driving all over.
It's about a 20 minute drive.
And we get to the hospital.
I get out.
I was there probably for an hour and a half,
two hours.
And then yesterday I read that I had strokes.
CNN Vector's, CNN.
Now, it's a mini stroke cycle.
I don't know what a mini stroke is, but it's
not good.
And it could be a day and does it matter?
Today it happens.
All of us.
Right.
Chip, these young ones, it's never going to
happen to them.
They're not.
Look at that.
But you know what happens.
But nothing happens.
So I went in.
I did that part of the physical.
The end result was he's very healthy.
They're very unhappy when they is that result.
So first first of all, imagine that this is
the behavior of an American president.
Just let let that sink in for a second.
But going further than that, you know, sometimes
people will write to me, they'll say, David,
why do you keep making a big deal out of this
totally outrageous behavior, given that it's
so common and we've become so used to it?
That's exactly why we should not be used to
it.
And we cannot allow this type of insanity
to be normalized.
That's why I keep talking about it, to try
to fight the normalization, to get back to
the main topic.
This is crazy because Trump keeps bringing
up how he didn't have strokes.
Nobody alleged that he had strokes.
Now, I know it's been speculated by random
people, but the allegations in the book that
Trump is responding to don't mention strokes.
It's sort of like when Trump started to bizarrely
focus in on acing his cognitive test, which
is a test that is not difficult and it's just
meant to screen out serious dementia.
Trump calling it a difficult test.
It's wild stuff.
It is unforced errors.
Trump talking about he and Biden should take
drug tests before debates because maybe Biden
took something before his debate with Bernie.
The speculation, of course, is that it's Trump
who sometimes seems all hopped up with the
dilated pupils and the sweating.
It's constant projection of this kind and
it's now become almost like we're headed to
some kind of boxing match with a way in anti-doping
screenings, more so than we are.
Presidential debates as far as the strokes
go.
Why does Trump keep talking about it?
Doesn't this just raise the suspicion even
more that he's constantly now talking about
strokes?
Nobody claimed that he had very, very strange
stuff.
And listen, Mike, my position is the following.
I don't know what happened to Trump on that
day.
What I do know is that the story of saying,
hey, you know what?
Let's right now, like right now, let's drive
over to Walter Reed to get a jump on my physical
for next year and spend hours there.
It doesn't make sense.
It doesn't pass the sniff test.
That's what I can tell you.
The fact that Trump keeps mentioning strokes
is certainly weird, if not concerning.